[Music]
five four three two one
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are now featuring Nicolas Paul briefs
wits how's it going man it's going
really well thanks for having me out
thanks for coming on the show yeah my
pleasure appreciate it yeah we have a
lot to talk about that we do and I'm
really excited because I think our minds
think in this cosmic perspective in this
evolutionary timeline in this how do we
design civilization moving forward and
and that's what you do right now here
with the director of development at the
long now foundation correct yeah two
years now mm-hmm yeah
give us a little love this little scoop
on what long now is up to oh so well
right now I mean the long now has been
around since 1996 it was started around
this project called the clock of the
long now that you may have heard about
its the 10,000 year clock in the desert
in West Texas it was started by Danny
Hillis who's now over at MIT and Danny
had this idea of building a clock that
was going to keep perfect time for the
next 10,000 years as a symbol for the
future the same way that the Pyramids of
Giza are a symbol for the past you know
in 96 a lot of technologists who grew up
with the year 2000 being this kind of
landing place for your ideas and your
projections about what future of
civilization is gonna be we knew we were
gonna blow past that in just another
four years so what happens after that do
we swap it out for the year 3000 the
year 2100 we pick another token number
what happens and Danny kinda want to get
ahead of that and kind of create this
this permission to think in long
timescales kind of these moonshot ideas
of saying you know what it sounds kind
of crazy to build a clock that's gonna
keep perfect time for 10,000 years it's
not an easy feat it's not an easy
engineering feat it's not an easy
fundraising feat nothing about it was
like an obvious thing and so it took a
lot of gumption and they did it and
people kind of glommed onto it he sent
out an email some of his friends close
people see what they thought about the
project and people got really
enthusiastic because there's they're
there right even when I tell people
about long now
in 2018 you know almost 25 years later
sometimes you know there's two kind of
buckets of people where you see people
half of them they don't get it they're
like okay that seems cool you know
whatever you guys in San Francisco you
guys have the wildest ideas but then
there's the other half of people that
there's light up and you realize right
away that you just struck something
they've been kind of thinking about in
the back of their mind and you've just
articulated and you've told them that
you've been building this for them and
so it's a really kind of an amazing
experience like the best part of my job
is I get to be for a lot of people the
the person who tells them what we're up
to and then yeah people get excited
about it so that clock project is really
what kicked off the idea of the long now
foundation continue with the train of
thought you just said that you get this
pleasure of delivering this message of
the long now this sort of this this
thought process of thinking in the long
term long term thought and you get to
share with people that hey we're we're
we're doing this we're helping people
with long-term thinking with our
projects and then they go wow thank you
for doing that that's so important that
tell us a little about just before you
keep going what does that what tell us
about that feeling for the other person
as you asked them more about what that
long now purport that long-term thinking
perspective means to them why do they
care mmm-hmm well you know I know what
that feeling is like because I've been
that person right at some point somebody
told me about longing I was like wait
what you're building a what and the
where and for how long and oh my god
this is incredible so I know what that
feels like and I see it reflected in
somebody else I'm like there's a lot of
empathy there right I kind of am taken
back to that moment right away and so I
think for a lot of people it's something
maybe they've thought about in the back
of their heads maybe at some point
late-night conversation with a friend
2:00 in the morning you're sitting in
the woods you're sitting in a hot tub
somewhere you're sitting in the hot
springs you're walking down Market
Street you know in the middle of the
night like we were saying how quiet it
gets and and you had this conversation
you say you know what do you what do you
think it's gonna happen in the next
thousand years ten thousand years are
humans still gonna be around what are we
gonna look like we're gonna have eyes
and we're gonna
you know are these archetypal things
going to be lasting forever like wow how
is the world gonna change how is it
going to stay the same these are really
interesting conversations and so I think
people have touched on it before they
ever come to long now I mean these
people that are lighting up I think
they're lighting up because it's same
way you'd recognize a friend you're like
oh I've had this conversation you guys
you guys just have this conversation
that's amazing and so the first minute
organization based on that conversation
yes the first move seems to be one of
just like excitement that this is a
thing and then there's a couple of
questions and then it usually lands with
like so so how can i how can I get
involved how can I be a part of this and
that's kind of what's cool about long
now too is it's been opened up so that
people can come and contribute ideas and
kind of share what their thoughts are
you know we're still finding ways of
doing this but the general idea for long
now is not to be a dogmatic institution
that says this is how you think long
term we're not a think-tank publishing
white papers right now where we say okay
this is how you do this for long term
this is how you do that for a long time
that's really not what we've been up to
we've been more Socratic we've been
creating opportunities and spaces and
experiences for people to ask those
questions of each other of themselves to
have that conversation and say like so
what do you think you know I'd I'd love
to maybe we can do this on the show but
I'd love to talk to you about what you
think is gonna happen in the next 10,000
years what kind of an arc or what kind
of a trajectory Humanity is on because I
find this to be the most interesting
thing is not so much having the answer
right not so much doing doing the jobs
yeah doing the job so well that it
closes up and nobody talks about it
anymore it's much less interesting to me
than opening up a whole new line of
inquiry and then once you get into this
space you can think about just about
everything from a long-term perspective
and it really changed the way you look
at things you know you've got these
Kepler posters over here so you start
thinking about you know interstellar
travel and space exploration I'm like
whoa where we gonna go in the next
10,000 years right you start looking at
this kind of stuff you start looking at
Benjamin Grant's photos from space and
you start thinking about the technology
that we have now what are we gonna do
with this technology and how is that
gonna change what it means to be human
how is that gonna change our
relationship to the planet to the
landscapes to the cities to the places
that we're taking care of like is it
gonna make us better stewards it's gonna
make us were stewards woody you know
what is our role in this and what is our
responsibility to the next generation
because as soon as you start thinking
these long timescales you get hit by
that sense of insignificance that some
people
really are excited about right and
there's a move there you have to see
yourself in contrast to something like a
mountain or something like the Pyramids
at Giza or maybe the clock of the long
now to really kind of recognize where
you are but then instead of making you
feel smaller I'm making you feel less a
gential there's something to be said for
this is giving you permission saying
you're at the beginning of a 10,000 year
story what are you gonna do it's
Saturday what are you gonna do Alan
you've got some ideas you got an idea of
where you want the world to go for the
next 10,000 years and you have
permission to get it started without
having the obligation to finish it
because you're in such a long arc that
you don't have the responsibility to
both kick something off and complete it
you can begin something it's gonna take
a few generations to finish right
projects that clock of the long now
we're coming up on 25 years and it's
under construction it's still being
built right we don't do this a whole lot
you have you have the Sagrada família
and some of these long-term projects are
amazing we love kind of collecting these
projects and these stories but there's
not a whole lot of incentive in our
current modern world for you to take on
something that you know you're not going
to complete to take on something and
then pass the baton to the next
generation and say not only like hey you
can finish this but I trust you to
finish in the way it needs to be
finished you don't have to read my mind
you don't have to go back into history
and do it exactly the way I did it I
don't want to constrain the next
generation with these I can pass that
baton and say go for it I trust you
you're gonna do a good job at this so
we're trying to do that in a
civilizational type and you know scale
but then there's also these projects
they're you know attacking different
things different aspects of ways you can
think long-term
you're into it I'm so into it I'm so
glad to hear that is so into it okay all
right so when you first have this
conversation with somebody they're
usually like you know I've had a
conversation like this before there's a
whole organization that does stuff like
this that's really exciting and they get
more excited they want to get involved
with it and then you have all these
different I really enjoyed how you're
talking about like passing the baton off
that's kind of what it felt like every
single generation has just passed the
baton off to the next generation to pick
up and continue running forth and
building a better world but we need to
know about this time scale in order to
better to better do that to better have
our minds expanded to the to these new
dimensions these new ways of thinking
and your this project long now what you
guys work on is has these has the clock
and you were talking about Danny Hillis
and the clocks this is in western Texas
and this where is this in western Texas
it's pretty much right where Texas New
Mexico and Mexico all come together New
Mexico New Mexico came right around
there and then it's built into a
mountain yeah and then it's a is it a
clock that has zero and then ten and
five thousand and then ten thousand like
yeah no not quite the the actual face of
the clock and I can't speak in in great
technical detail about it but the actual
face of the clock is a star field and
it's actually gonna dark it's a star
field and it actually helps you orient
yourself in in space and so that's kind
of letting you know what time it is you
know there's gonna be a Gregorian date
as well we use a ten year date format
the DECA millennial date format so for
us it's the year 0 2018 yeah and that
you know the story behind that was that
Danny was doing some modeling for the
clock in Excel it was crashing Excel
because he was projecting things out
into the year 10,000 in Excel didn't
know what to do with it so now we've
kind of adopted it as like a token
reminder of like the 10,000 year time
frame that we're kind of concerned with
but the clock itself should have you
know a Gregorian readout this star field
which is the rete and actually you know
I don't know if I have a business card
ami I would show you what the REIT looks
like
right there on the back that actually
shows that's helping you kind of orient
yourself in that star field and so
astrolabes used to use these to kind of
orient people and so the clock is going
to use one of those as well yeah when
you get to the clock it's going to have
the what is this what is this what is
this
that's the REIT what's a REIT yeah it's
like a guide to reading that field it's
actually letting you know like where the
North Star is for example showing you
where you are in relation to that and if
you star field so it's pretty
interesting in fact like we have a for
anybody who's interested in learning
more about that we know nothing yeah for
anybody who's interested in learning
more about that we actually have some
stuff on our blog about like reads
astrolabes or aries if you've been to
our bar the interval here in San
Francisco
you've seen the or re which is that
mechanical contraption that shows the
positions of all of the human eye
visible planets in the solar systems all
six of those and so that's that that was
actually taken around to teach people
about the heliocentric model in the
universe was like oh here you go here
I'll show you you have a constant
positioning of where the other visit the
other visible planets are in our source
than you have a as in as in if as in if
you're at the interval and then Mars is
over here then and you're looking this
way then you could look outside go
outside and look up in the skies long
it's over the horizon line and you could
go and see where it is if you're if it's
not if the light pollution isn't bad it
too bad basically in a nutshell yeah the
one of the intervals actually turned off
because we had issues of people grabbing
onto it and we had to recalibrate it and
so it's actually unplug it's not an
accurate representation every now and
then somebody will go there and line up
all the planets or something and people
be like oh my god I can't believe that's
happening is that happening outside
right now no no there's no it's not it's
not fully functional right now okay so I
have I I mean we could talk about we
could talk about this which I know very
very very little about nothing about we
could talk about the cosmic field on the
face of the clock which I also don't
know anything about there's so much to
learn about that there's a Gregorian you
sit next to it so people can see 0 2 0 1
a
and be like oh yeah I actually really
like that in a nutshell video did you
see that one Kirk's Cassatt in the Moshe
Salah scene calendar policy calendar yes
I bought one of those did you buy one of
those I didn't know I had one I had the
2017 one next to my closet it was
awesome every single day you get Hein to
see the year 12,000 and 18 it was kind
of idea yeah I like that I think that's
actually a pretty cool date format as
well puts again like these first 10,000
years of life like we can jump I guess
maybe I'll mention this point but we the
first 10,000 years of figuring out how
to live on land and grow food on land
and and slowly build up civilization
those first 10,000 years until today
we're now we're in 12,000 18 I really
like that format because it rather than
no civilizations only 2000 years old
enough 12,000 years old it gives you a
better idea of where we've really come
from but okay so I wanted to say these
other projects then we can maybe come
back to that but so the the clock of the
long now is this is the the importance
of seeing civilization on a 10,000 year
scale and then you have the interval so
it's a a bar a meeting place for art and
science together and then you have the
Rosetta project as well and so then I
guess we can talk about this project
because I think this one is over over
the span of the last ten thousand years
and even quite a bit before that
civilization was developing with all of
the different languages that we were
using to communicate with each other now
you were teaching me there's only 7,000
languages left we lose a language every
14 days every two weeks we lose a
language so the Rosetta project's trying
to log as many of the languages as
possible yeah in part so so the clock
you know I can kind of tie all this
together in a nice thread and that's
that the clock was this amazing idea it
was brilliant everybody recognized it
for being what it was
I mean Stuart brand who's a
counterculture figure out here in San
Francisco but he's been involved in so
many different projects over the years
it's really
fascinating Stuart brand got involved
and said there should be a library with
the clock there should be something
there something cultural something
civilizational that we can pass on pass
forward to the next generations so you
think about a library and that makes
sense you okay cool let's do a library
and then you get into these interesting
canonical discussions so the library
that we've been building is at the bar
it's at the interval it's a
floor-to-ceiling library
it's about 3,000 volumes roughly but the
idea is that you're gonna build a
tightly curated cannon that is the books
that you would want to have if you had
to jumpstart civilization so what kind
of books would you want you you want to
have Shakespeare you'd want to have
Plato you'd want to know how to make
steel you want to know how to do
penicillin you know you know there's so
many things you want to do you want to
capture all of that you know we have an
oxford english dictionary up there you
know there's a you know it's like
Britannica encyclopedia Britannica's up
there it's like all the books that you
would the done thing right you would
have all these books there and then the
question becomes well do you do it in
English you know we're in an
english-speaking country so that makes
sense for us but you know and then if
you have like bore hits do you do bore
hasten English that's the only way I've
ever read bore Hayes but you know that's
not you know his native language and so
she's starting to get these interesting
canonical conversations and pretty soon
they actually become they start to like
it's it's kind of we're talking about
earlier about conversations being so
interesting the Socratic thing that's
like opening a space and holding a space
for us to discuss what we think like I
think there's room for a really
interesting discussion there about what
language should include and so this this
library also kind of seeds a lot of
conversation about the future what we're
gonna want what we what our
responsibilities are to this world and
the future generations so that all kind
of came together and I think we kind of
agreed on well if you're gonna put it in
any language you're gonna need a key to
get it into the other languages because
you're not gonna have a guarantee that
somebody who finds the library is gonna
speak English and so you know let's kind
of look at all the languages and so
there's a lot of field work that's been
done to collect all these languages
these 7,000 there's field workers all
over the globe that are trying to
capture that in fact dr. Laura welcher
who's the director of the Rosetta
project you know she was working on
Potawatomi which is an indigenous
language here in North America I think
actually back where I'm from like near
the Chicago Milwaukee area and so she
was doing fieldwork out there to collect
some of that stuff and so all of this
gets collect dictionaries grammars
Swadesh lists parallel text translations
of Genesis parallel text translations of
the United Declaration of Human Rights
all this kind of gets compiled into a
data corpus and the question is how do
you save that for ten thousand years now
at ten thousand your time skill you're
gonna have to deal with something like a
digital Dark Age the fact that all these
things that we store on hard drives all
these things that we have stored in our
computers those are all going to be
ephemeral on a long time scale and if
they're not ephemeral physically because
of something like an electromagnetic
pulse or a solar flare they're gonna be
ephemeral in the sense that they're
encoded in such a way that it's
difficult to decode them if you were to
give me a CD right now of like your band
or something and I wanted to listen to
it I'd probably have to scratch my head
and like look around my house and see if
I have a disk drive somewhere so like
even just something that's a couple of
decades old becomes almost inaccessible
within just you know a very short time
period so what would you do so the
Rosetta project started working with
Berkeley National Labs some other folks
to figure out how we could shrink an
analog image so like a screen printed
t-shirt if you ever I don't have ever
actually done a screen print but it's
awesome it's a lot of fun if you can
imagine something that you want to
actually get that analog image just
shrunk all the way down so initially the
initial technology was a focused gallium
ion beam that was kind of basically
engraving these disks at like a seven
nanometer scale so each page of language
documentation on these nickel disks it's
about five human hairs wide so you can
fit a lot of information on it the
original Rosetta disks there's like
15,000 pages of language documentation
all on like a three inch disk so that's
a good way to store it you know um you
know 30 X or 60 X Jewelers loop you'll
be able to unpack everything that's on
there and you know but again it seems
these conversations you'd have to have
eyes we're gonna have eyes in here 7,000
these are interesting conversations
they're questions that you know experts
in the field can unpack and talk about
and discuss and stuff Laura is actually
an expert in how we speak to future
generations and to you know X trust
'real intelligences so she is on the
board of directors from medi the
messaging to extraterrestrial
intelligence which is so great on earth
so it opens up dr. Laura Walter Walter
yeah so it kind of opens up these
questions so all of these projects you
know the clock and in the library and
then the Rosetta disk we're kind of
opening more and more questions we're
not closing up boxes and saying we
figured that out file that away
kind of saying cool here's another area
of inquiry that we can kind of use our
minds to unpack and use conversations to
unpack together so so that project kind
of you know was what that was that's
what's still going on we're still trying
to figure out how do we store all that
information because I joke around that
like you know those original rosetta
disks cost quite a bit of money to make
they were very expensive to fabricate
you know a couple years ago we made some
smaller ones about a coin size that you
can actually wear around your neck and
those were a little bit less expensive
the technology's advanced significantly
since we started the project I'd like to
think that in my lifetime that
technology will eventually get to the
spot where the back of my business card
is not going to have a picture of the
wreath but it'll have the entire manual
for civilization on the back of it we'll
be able to store all of this information
in a way that's easy to decode and it'll
be cheap enough that I can hand them out
like business cards so that's kind of
where that projects going figuring out
new ways to archive information how are
we gonna do this for you know how are we
gonna archive and save things on a
Millenial time scale and then have
conversations to see if we can do that
better
so all that kind of comes around to this
idea of extinction you and I were
talking about a little bit earlier when
I was having coffee and that's that you
know when you're looking at a 10,000
year time scale the first thing anyone
will tell you is that you can't plan for
10,000 years
nobody can plan for 10,000 years the
only thing you would know about your
plan is it's gonna completely wrong and
so what you want to do on a 10,000 your
time scale is actually preserve
possibilities for the next generations
because once something disappears once
something's extinct like a language you
know you're living in a world in which
you no longer have access to that
language or if a species goes extinct do
you know you're living in a world in
which that's not going to be the case
anymore you don't have mammoths anymore
right and so that that constrains the
future and I think one of the maybe
normative claims that we would make
would be that preserving possibility for
the future is a good idea right again
there's room for conversation here and I
think like that that's that's something
I'd like to see more conversations about
but I think on the whole you want to
trust future generations and in order to
trust them and kind of give them the
baton in the best condition you can you
have to give them maximal optionality
you have to give them as many degrees of
freedom as possible because you don't
know maybe they do want to speak another
language maybe there's a good reason to
do this play or write that poem in this
language
images are fascinating and I'm not a
language not but the more and more I've
talked to Laura about how an entire
worldview can really get captured in the
way a language is structured and spoken
and shared it's mind-blowing and so yeah
making sure that future generations have
those we've got 7,000 around you know
let's let's make sure we still have
7,000 around accessible available for
people logged
yeah hugged and they've resurrected a
couple of languages I think it's Miami
but there's there stories about people
who kind of brought them back and then
to that same and we're also working with
a project called revive and restore that
Stuart Brandon his wife Ryan Phelan are
running which is trying to bring back
the woolly mammoth
that's kind of the mic drop elevator
pitches bring it back the woolly mammoth
but they're also working on you know a
number of other organisms including the
passenger pigeon black-footed ferret the
Great Auk there's a lot of things
they're working on using genomic
technology to maybe possibly undo some
of what's been done right so we live in
a world without woolly mammoths and
there's certain consequences to that it
actually turns out there's certain like
a climatological consequences right
William amis with good climate change
mitigators and so there's a reason why
you'd want to bring them back they have
an ecological function and so it's going
to be interesting to see is that
technology progresses we're having more
and more responsibility for our planet
we're being able to look at it and kind
of say oh wow I mean just look at any of
these photos here you can see the impact
that we've had on the surface of this
planet like it comes with certain
responsibilities rights to a brand is
said and you know we are as gods and may
as well get good at it
I think it's a really good way of
capturing this moment in time you know
when you can bring back William amis
like okay I talk to people all the time
who kind of reference Jurassic Park or
they reference like oh my god how do you
you know you're you're just gonna do
this kind of stuff and it's like no no
that's why you're having a conversation
that's why you're opening up the space
for people to discuss this and share
their thoughts on it you kind of learn
from people you open up a space for yeah
there's so much to talk about around
each of these projects so let's see what
we can do with unpacking it yeah there
were times along the way that I was like
I want to go and unpack that one and
then I want to go and unpack that one
and
maybe along the way I'll start doing
that a little bit more because now I
have like four things done packet it's
it's a lot what if you cover all the
books yeah yeah we did almost where we
got a couple more to go but yeah we're
yeah exactly almost yeah so okay so
check so check this out as you talked
about the manual for civilization we
talked a lot on the show about the
importance of the parent helping teach
the child when the child's born into the
world kind of some sort of basic
foundational understanding of the world
that they live in and so I think the
manual would be a really good thing for
the parent to be teaching the child hey
this is where we came from this is who
we are this is where we're going so what
we're working on etc and I'm really
happy to hear that there is this that
there's this manual and that the manual
of like you were saying penicillin
optics electricity all these different
types of things language that are really
important across other languages so that
way anyone in the world could see like
here these are these fundamental things
that we would teach in order to start a
civilization then that led you into the
idea of preserving language as well and
then that led into the understanding of
extinctions extinctions of languages
extinctions of species and how do we
bring back ones that we want to have
because it's interesting to say that
we've done it and that we know that how
to do it and that this is a way for us
to move forward
it's a forward thinking idea to be able
to bring back things that have died in
order to be like hey we are like you
said we are in control we are gods so we
may as well start acting like we can
we'll figure out how to work together in
prosperous it was an ecological function
right a lot of these animals that are
gone they actually they were stewards of
an environment and in kind of critical
pieces in a kind of a network and so in
those cases a sequester and extra carbon
or something yeah it's less it's less
than like let's do it because then we
can then we have it's it's not to make
light of extinction it's not let's do it
because then we don't have to worry
about extinction anymore
back that's really not like the angle
that we at least that we're going on for
you know for this it some utility behind
it um there's there's like a balance
that can be upset in these ecosystems
when you know species goes extinct and
they had a role they had like a job to
do right I'm kinda like we all have jobs
in the economy right they had like a job
in the economy of their their system and
then when they're gone you know there
are certain situations in which no one
moves in to do that that jobs just being
undone and maybe that's the way that
evolution has sort of been on a
trajectory because over the past I think
it's like what 90% of all species that
have ever existed are extinct now Wow
90% yeah so it just but that's the
classic I think it's 90 million species
of extinct and now there's 10 million
left or so I think that's what it is and
that that might just be the trajectory
as a species becomes extinct than the
ecosystem changes in that sense so maybe
it is if we do want to play God we are
going to impact that ecosystem in a way
that we are unsure about unless we do
some simulation projections and figure
out what will it happen if we brought
that back into the ecosystem but yeah
there's always this purpose behind what
you're doing what would you say is kind
of a you know the grand purpose is this
long-term thinking but this but like the
overall purpose of of especially like
preserving like let's talk about the
extinction one for example like what
would you say is like the overall
purpose you were kind of getting into
that a little bit yeah I think restoring
ecological function is is kind of the
idea here they the main takeaway is that
there's a role here that we can restore
and what you have a role that would be
restored in an ecosystem yeah so here's
a good one right so the passenger pigeon
we talked about that a little bit last
passenger pigeon went extinct not that
long ago is like 1914 right but these
things used to black the sky out flocks
of passenger pigeons used to be like
millions it's just a while to think
about right like I've you know I don't
even know if I have a model for what
that would be like to have a flock of
passenger pigeons block out the Sun but
this is from the reports we have this is
what happened and they were kind of like
a natural wildfire so you have so many
pigeons coming and descending on trees
that the trees are falling over and then
you have all the pigeons returning all
of those those you know all the nitrogen
all the minerals back in
the soil and so you ended up having like
this this kind of natural wildfire that
move across the plains and now they're
gone so now you just kind of see the
ecosystem kind of adapting right and in
some ways it's good you know like you
said like sometimes there's this
inexorable you know evolution of things
and they're moving on and like things
move on but there's also a sense in
which again like if we have the ability
to bring it back and I was doing
something really good for that
environment it was promoting
biodiversity or like you know there's
all this other there's all these other
considerations in that Network to look
at and say like Oh what do we really do
here we we think we just lost a pigeon
but maybe so much more is happening
right and so kind of talking about that
discussing that figuring out what it is
we can do what it is we should do what
kind of timescales we should do it on
there's so many questions there you
could I mean there are entire
conferences where people are just
discussing exactly that how do we do
this responsibly how do we do this
acacia Slee you know yeah and so I so I
love that there's a project in the world
in which people are saying we should be
talking about this we have a unique
leverage point here to kind of maybe not
so much undo the damage we've done but
to increase our power to be good
stewards of the environment this is
another way in which we can be a good
steward and so if we can do that what
are our responsibilities and like I
don't get about this well so we see an
ecosystem there might be a benefit of
bringing back to passenger pigeon so we
bring it back and we analyze the way
that it impacts the ecosystem and okay
and there's and there might be a couple
examples of how we can bring back
certain species and augment our
ecosystems okay okay and then and then
with language we have the we're bringing
we're bringing back languages that have
been lost in order to or we're at least
logging the ones that have been lost or
as close to have been lost as possible
we're trying to log them so we can say
that oh yeah this this society developed
in this way and we can tell from their
language so oh he's interesting like
when two linguistics and I'm sure that
her name was Linda let dr. Laura Laura
Laura Laura Walter I'm sure that she
knows of like George George Zipp and
like Liz it's law and linguistics
and the Pareto principle but it's so
interesting how even like historical
languages still applied with the peretta
proto principle still applies to them
that that only 20% of the words that are
that are used to account for 80% of all
of the words used so like the of and
which to like those sort of words count
for like 80% of all the things you say
and like all the other 80% of words that
are like much longer words or only like
20% of the things that are said is there
longer they there they take in they're
used less often and so it's interesting
how civilizations still used similar
tendencies with our languages even from
the last throughout evolution and so by
logging that language and by logging the
languages we have today as that maybe we
should talk about this one as a language
is gone every 14 days is like why is
that is that a tribe of people that
we're using a language either maybe a
couple of the ones died off that were
the last ones that knew the language
economic and political pressures for
them to adapt and learn the language of
the country that is now prospering and
using a new language or the newer
versions or dialects of it and that way
they stopped using that one and there's
no one being taught it anymore so all of
those all those are reasons why we're
losing the languages yeah and they are
the tail languages like you said they're
the ones that are only being spoken by a
few dozen people right or maybe a few
hundred people or even threatened
languages right and so yeah for all of
those reasons from feeling pressure for
the being economic or political pressure
and just from age right people aren't
speaking anymore the next generation
didn't bother to learn it they were
educated in different things and there's
I mean history's rife with stories and
people who you know the next generation
is educated speaking out the language
and it's you know there's a violence to
it right I've I kind of forcing somebody
away from their own language right of
the way that they've spoken and shared
their worldview so there's there's
there's a certain humanitarian angle to
it as well preserving these link
witches so we are like keeping them safe
for the next generation to make
decisions but we're also kind of saying
there's this protection kind of thing
where you say no like we're not we're
kind of taking a stand and saying it's
not okay to eliminate languages right
we're not just gonna like wipe them
clean and say like oh we don't need it
English is great works great works good
enough for me right there's something
there's something very uh there's
dignity in it and there's history yeah
there's one day I mean we'll look back
at the Rosetta project and we'll see
that there was a word that was used to
describe a feeling that there is no word
in the English language that we use to
describe that feeling yes I can give you
an example I actually do it I'm gonna
butcher this Laura's gonna kill me she's
I'm gonna butcher this I don't know
exactly what it is but basically and I
think it's Potawatomi but again I'm
probably getting some of these details
wrong but there's I think it's proud of
me there's a language in which one can
do something and there's a modifier
right see we have like modifiers like
you know like you I guess like um like
you have gender modifiers in like French
or something right like or Spanish right
you have like like the meal fork or the
female knife or whatever you know you
have these kind of small modifiers and
then like you have like in the town you
have like ECMO for big or something
right or like Ito and Spanish for little
right so you these weird little
modifiers you can tag on and in
Pottawattamie they have modifiers for
agency so you can walk like like
academic walks you can walk like a
toddler walks you can walk like a rock
walks and so they kind of use this for
like poetic effect for rhetorical effect
super instant we don't have anything
like this in English there's no way I
can take a verb and then kind of like
tag something on and then kind of adds a
whole world away anymore thing it'd
almost be like it's kind of like an
adding a descriptor to a verb isn't that
kind of like an adverb kind of yeah a
little bit yeah but running is you can't
you would have to use a whole word
before running to describe like running
a marathon versus running to an
appointment versus running like speed
walking totally we can get around to it
and express some of these things right
that's how we can talk about it but
there's just like this beauty in the
economy rather than language yes right
you'd make a prefix or something though
and again I don't yeah I don't know the
details could be a suffix could be a
prefix it could be like that we couldn't
dig that wasn't figure out there are
there are and and even in I think we've
talked abouts on the show before but in
in Hindi there's a bunch of different
ways to say love and then we only have
like love here it is like love so so
even things like that
what kind of love Ron always jokes
around and says that he loves Chinese
food that's that's right and that's it
that's real love and love Chinese food
my disco shows The Pink Floyd album yeah
but like Ron also has a nephew and a
niece and so you know so then he has a
different kind of love for them right
Ron yeah yeah I would imagine yeah so
like his uh so then like but he has to
use the same word love with this for two
of these different like food versus
humans like it's like a but there's but
there's a different feeling to say so
just using that example and launching
off that that's the feeling of living in
a constrained situation yeah where you
don't have those other options within
arm's reach right so we can feel what it
feels like say ah there's this thing I
want just thing I want to do and I I
can't do it because I'm constrained in a
certain way right that's the idea of
preserving possibilities for the next
10,000 years that's this idea and
there's so many different like themes we
can take with it whether it's languages
or species or anything but this idea
that like yeah you don't want to find
yourself in like kind of in a
constrained future in which you don't
have these options you want to trust the
future to do good work and you want to
give them all the tools you can right
and that's another Stewart Brand thing
was access to tools right the Whole
Earth Catalog this idea was you should
have access to great tools yeah someone
should tell you where to get good pants
someone should tell you where to get
good glasses for your water someone
should tell you
everything you need to build a piece of
furniture you should know how to get
access to those tools it's important
that's what the internet helps us do
it's access to intellectual tools it's
access to information and so there's
something to this it's like really
important that we recognize like it's
always better when is it a horse a horse
my kingdom for a horse you never want to
be in a situation which I here in need
of that thing and it's gone you don't
have it it's really like oh there's
another really good example is the
George Gilder taught this to us that you
would have a civilization that would go
out and fish and they would go out and
fish on their canoes and they'd go
fishing and fishing and then they had
similar then the generation would die
and their kids would go fish and their
kids would grow up and then they would
die and their kids would go fishing
fishing and it would just keep happening
for like 100 years or something and then
the canoes would break and then the kids
didn't know how to build canoes because
that acknowledged that history that
teachings was gone they didn't document
how to build canoes they didn't practice
augmenting how to build canoes and
making them better over time so I think
that that's the this is this is one of
these reasons why it's important to keep
it not only to expand the language and
so that we have less of these
limitations with trying to describe
certain things we can augment our
languages and make them better and
include things like feeling how much
feeling can we add to language but then
there's also like you said like how do
you build a good piece of furniture or
how do you mold a good glass how do you
give a good haircut how do you write a
good novel how do you etcetera so that
retaining that sort of wisdom as well
this kind of this kind of makes me feel
a little bit like like we're trying to
retain like a digital ledger of like
everything and it's probably like not
that like if we had the capacity to
retain a digital ledger of everything in
something like DNA that was easy to read
and write and that was really small then
that would make sense like it's fine we
can totally read and write in DNA and
capture everything that's ever
they're working on it yeah I know but at
the same time that's like I don't really
care if you purchased a taco at two
o'clock on a and I don't think
civilization needs to keep that in a
digital ledger forever yeah it begs some
interesting questions about how we
filter culture because culture is that
ledger
it's the sum accumulation of all of our
stories right so in Western culture it's
the Western stories it's Shakespeare
it's the Lion King right but like you
know there's other cultures and other
stories and other canons of ways they've
kind of figured out how do I pass down
to my children and my children's
children and children's children as
economically as possible everything they
need to know how to act in the world
like that's a really interesting
question and culture is kind of our
answer to it it's it's less this
conscious thing right in fact like it's
there's something to be really
interestingly said about it being an
unconscious thing that like culture
what-what lasts last because it's it
needs to be in the Canon if it was
disposable we dispose with it like
carrying information across Millennia's
like resource intensive right it's not
easy like to read all the books like yes
it stands you and I are never gonna read
all the books in the manual for
civilization it breaks my heart I walk
into work every day I look at those
books and I just know I am NOT gonna
read them all but we've saved them and
the question is like how why some books
got burned some books got banned in some
books you have to read in high school or
you can't graduate high school right and
so that's kind of how we decide about
you know how do we teach people to give
a good haircut how do we teach people
how to be in love how do we teach people
how to raise a family and find a job and
go through despair like we've kind of
collected these stories because they're
good they're useful so that's kind of a
cultural question so yeah
keeping that it's why it's a genius move
to want to keep that with the clock
right like you can't just have a clock
spend you know passing a message
thousands of years into the future and
not offer kind of the payoff like here's
the culture here's something you might
need this I don't know I've no idea what
situation you're in but if things were
bad all of this it's gonna be really
helpful
ah should we talk about the manual for
civilization in the interval because I
don't think we talked about the interval
yet we did a little but okay well I
think talking about it more is a great
idea
okay let's talk about it in this sense
this is a question that we asked on a
show a lot what would be some good
foundational principles for a parent to
instill into their child oh man I don't
know if I'm an authority on that matter
certainly wouldn't be speaking ex
cathedra for long now but I you know I
think um Nick resilience it's like one
of the most important things I think of
in the in general broad category it's
like how do you go through like near
total defeat and actually come out on
the other side and be okay
possibly even improve your situation
right that's a crazy idea it's a wild
idea cuz there's nothing intuitive about
it like inductively if you were going
through the world and things got really
really really really really bad there's
no part of you that's gonna know that
that's not that you shouldn't just give
up right there's no party that's gonna
get you kind of through that dark night
of the soul and up on the other side
where you might be stronger for it right
what does it Nietzsche say that well you
know great suffering makes great right
and I think everybody that's really
worked on something that's not easy like
running a series you know what I mean
like that you guys are doing here like
there's long nights there's difficult
conversations there's financial
considerations to come into play there's
like opportunity cost of other things
you could do like any time you're doing
something that you care about and it
matters to you and then you're gonna get
good at it it's gonna get tough and so
when it gets tough how do you share with
your kid how do you share with the
future generations that this is no this
is this is kind of a feature not a bug
like yeah there's gonna be lots of this
get ready for it get used to it get
comfortable with it actually learn how
to navigate through the chaos to come
back out into a more ordered situation
and maybe bring some more order into the
world with you from kind of that
underworld journey that you go on so
that's the monomyth right like so I
guess when I'm making an advocacy for
I'm advocating that we continue telling
the monomyth but that's super important
yeah tell me God knows it's helped me in
a couple of situations and I'm sure you
two I'm sure anybody who's come to any
maturity in their life
kind of been on that hero's journey and
kind of gone into the place where it was
tough and it's good that there's people
there shouting at you know it's gonna be
alright you're gonna be cool on the
other side of this dress I think a lot
of what you just said is incredible to
build up resilience in life and to teach
children that but you know there have
been so many studies now done on if
there isn't a figure around the kid that
helps them learn about resilience then
the likelihood that that kid falls into
the underworld into the chaos is
actually quite high
really yeah it's money you got to have
either a parent or a mentor or a
counselor or another family member a
relative or close friend or one of those
that at least makes one of what you were
discussing all of that resilience
understanding like help them help the
child understand resilience and how the
and how they'll come forth as a stronger
more solid being oh that's beautiful
isn't it Ron what did you pull up this
is the rosetta disk the rosetta disk
this is the Rosetta disk and I believe
this is the version that was landed on
comet 67p in the fall of 2016 so do you
remember that comment shaped like a
rubber duckie and the European Space
Agency sent one of these up with the
Rosetta mission they called they called
long now and said would you like to put
a Rosetta disc on the Rosetta mission
and they then crash-landed that little
probe onto the Comets this version of
this disc is sitting on comet 67p
somewhere outside of Mars orbit with all
of human language so it's an off
planetary backup of everything we need
so it's yeah as you can see it kind of
starts in the the big languages kind of
spirals and round so you follow it with
your eye right says languages of the
world here and then it kind of spirals
around until you're down at the nano
scale and like I said those pages of
language documentation end up being
about five human hairs wide each so who
owns the rights to data we're gonna get
in trouble for using I mean oh no I
think you know I think I think you
should be totally fine with that three
um I can double-check for you but I
think you should be good nice I mean
again because it's your design in
long-term archiving there's an idea
called locks have you heard about the
locks locks loc KSS lots of copies keep
stuff safe yeah so there's this idea
that the way to get this information to
the hands that it needs to get into in
the year seven thousand eight thousand
whatever right the way to get it into
the hands is just to make sure there's
tons of it make sure it's everywhere so
yeah so I think having another
appearance of this disc here on your
show is a totally good move yeah I think
the rights holders will be okay with it
thank you thank you very much yeah good
good caller on can you pull up the book
the clock do you photos of the clock
from the long now there are some
interesting videos of the clock
installation they're up on Twitter yes
there there's some there's a new video
as the installation there's some
beautiful photos in the mountain
floating around our website and stuff
but yeah there's some stuff it trickles
out I mean it's a long-term project and
it's kind of always been handled in this
really patient really measured way where
yeah they've never said here's the
opening date we need to have it done by
that day they've never said this is you
know oh you know the details that have
been released have been the details
they're like this is the story this is
the myth of the clock so this reminds me
talk about this yes absolutely
Bristlecone pine long now.org
established zero one nine nine six so
Bristlecone pines neo bursar complaints
heard of them they are the longest
living non clonal organisms on planet
earth long's living oh that is the
prototype clock that I believe is
currently in the London Science Museum
that turned on at the turn of the
millennium
so y2k was happening I was in Chicago in
my basement probably panicked holding
batteries and water and everything
getting ready for the end times and the
long now board was turning this guy on
so this is this is beautiful it's kind
of proving out a concept kind of
checking it's the actual clock of the
long now in Texas is is significantly
different in its design and it's connect
form factors but I think the general
idea behind it the way it goes about
keeping time is very similar it's
beautiful yeah it's pretty antsy you can
see the wreath there what you're talking
about
yeah it's the REIT in the star field
you're gonna round it on the outside
there's the Gregorian this is I could
dial there that'll let you
what year it is but you know yeah and I
wish I got I wish I knew more about
reading the read and could tell you like
exactly what the history of that is and
astrolabes it's the way we would read
star fields but reading star fields for
time yeah so Ron do you want to get a
zoom on the coin on the coin yeah so
carpe millennium see some millennium use
the millennium and then there's that
same yeah would you call it a reit our
ete for anybody out there who wants to
look into it a reat and then on this
side is that's the Bristlecone pine yeah
so the original mountain for the clock
is in nevada it's just outside a Great
Basin National Park it's Mount
Washington that was gonna be the
original site in the top of that
mountain
you know it like what I think of like
eleven twelve thousand feet is the
largest privately-held stand of
Bristlecone pine trees in the world some
of those pine trees are older than the
pyramids of giza the thousands of years
thousand year old trees yeah I think
there's one actually in California that
might be up to 5,000 years old
absolutely mind-blowing I got to spend
some time out with them last summer and
it was there's a special moment multi
thousand year old trees would be really
neat to be with yeah it's like our
spirit animal yeah I Bristlecone pine
this long now spirit animal yep is um
now what's the story behind these coins
so that's a challenge coin and so for
anybody who doesn't know to challenge
coin as we talked about this a little
bit earlier a challenge coin was is
military in origin and in the branches
of the military if you wanted to express
gratitude or camaraderie with somebody
who is maybe like not at the same rank
as you there's really not a whole lot of
appropriate ways for you kind of bust
ranks and express gratitude nor is there
a way for you to kind of express
gratitude in a concrete fashion across
branches in the military
so there's a great 99% invisible podcast
with Roman Mars about challenge coins I
send it to everybody when they get one
of these I'm like you got to go listen
to this it's like 20 minutes in a
nutshell here's the story but you'll
have high-ranking generals who behind
them in their offices just have like
Bragg sheets of all the challenge coins
they've collected over their career
show how cooperative they've been like
how how helpful how many friends they
have in all these different places
around the world and all these different
branches so challenge coins are kind of
a thing there's an interesting you know
probably apocryphal stories about people
who brought challenge coins to the bar
and you pull your challenge coin out and
you call coin check you throw it on the
bar and everybody else has to pull their
challenge coin out and throw it on the
bar and if they don't person who doesn't
have their coin on him buys the next
round of drinks so you can try that at
the bar you can try the interval see
what happens maybe some you might get
somebody who pulls out a challenge coin
on you and then it's on you so that's
the story behind those and yeah it's
nice little artifacts sure a challenge
coin expresses gratitude across ranks as
well as across fields yeah and so then
would the what a field in maybe like
some field in Southeast Asia now someone
that's doing some sort of work in
Southeast Asia would they have a same
challenge coin that somebody that's
doing work in South America whatever
they would have different challenge
coins but they would be able to gift the
there different manufacturer Queens to
each other right I think the ideas that
you generally mint them from your own
money like it's not like the military
has a budget for challenge coins my
understanding that people would just go
get them made and so you get as many
coins made as you have people who want a
challenge coin for their group for their
division yeah and so you are now holding
our challenge coin the long notes are no
long now challenge coin there's only one
sees the [ __ ] millennium baby 15
minutes ago
that's our 15 minute signal give it to
us or on standby standby because I want
to I want to hear it hear it is that
that's how you know you have 15 all
right yeah all right and then the and
then the now comes the timer hourglass
comes out yeah all right oh except this
is a 15 minute glass interesting
hourglass it has actually named after an
hour yeah I guess I never really took
the time to think about that either but
that
a great time keeping device right we've
been talking about ways of keeping time
and ways of conceiving time our glasses
are 15 minute glasses quarter glasses
are such a good way of really starting
to feel time yeah like I'm sure you
probably are very familiar with the
feeling that gets when it gets to the
bottom you're like okay I got a Rex
question I'm getting better at it yeah
so it's an interesting device to help
you kind of understand where you are
yeah and we're in that business we're in
the business of the opposite direction
getting you to understand where you are
in the broadest possible terms like
you're in the middle of a twenty
thousand year narrative yeah so you
don't have to rush you got time you can
pass the baton you can start a project
without feeling obliged to finish it so
I think it's a really important concept
that we don't have incentives in our
culture a lot oh we're talking about
time I'm sorry we're talking about time
you chime it in for time Ron well the
whole time thing has always been you
know cuz I I understand the past present
future happening all at once it's I
understand it doesn't you know I'm doing
the best I can to you know navigate
through this world in three dimensions
but yeah the whole time thing I'll after
the show I'm going to take a drill and
drill it in my head I'm doing my best to
navigate this three dimensions what is
that I brought you something this is
gift number two look at the amount of
gifts that are have this is a single
malt scotch it's drinking heart of a
long-term thinking scotch program at the
interval oh if you've seen the ceiling
there are some bottles that are hanging
over the bar and those are the donors
that have helped us construct the bar
and keep it open and in order to kind of
express our gratitude and then also kind
of get in this cool tradition was the
idea of the bottle keep which is a
Japanese tradition where you keep your
bottle in the bar and so st. George
spirits in Alameda which is arguably the
best distiller in the world right there
just total craftsman total pros they
distill in the Eau de Vie tradition they
make a single malt for us they made 15
barrels and every year we cork another
barrel so this is three or I thought I'd
bring you some three or four Wow sorry
you scotch guy really a premium eat or
not Scotland so I think it's true so
that's also Ronnie you on
grab a little glass for yourself as well
are you gonna drink them all I think we
should I think we should enjoy a little
bit of a little while we were in the
last 15 minutes here yeah I don't I
typically don't don't drink those when
I'm when I'm when I'm when I presented
really nice I can't even believe you
brought your own [ __ ] glasses I did
it was the last thing I thought before I
left the bar last night I was like you
know what I think it'd be kind of nice
for us to have a sip of scotch on the
show Wow let's do it Ronnie
Wow a toast Lee are you on the center
shot okay okay cool so interesting so
let's um let's take let's take a little
let's take a little with Wow holy cow
that smells real yeah yeah it's it's
made from a single malt and this
particular one again has been Aging in
wood for three years but that same that
same booze is gonna be aging for 15
years so every year our bottle donors
get to kind of try the next version of
it so but yeah we're on we're on you're
three it's my favorite of the bunch I
want to make this too tool along now to
everything that the long now has done in
the way that they that they inspire
long-term thinking around the world to
you guys and to society prospering and
flourishing yeah you're here cheers
Cheers
[Music]
what's that the wood that's a good
question I have no idea what the story
is there there's got to be a good long
now story about why people will tap the
table but I think that's just a habit
I've gotten into you know when you then
I think that is right you do the
woodford yeah he did that's wrong though
yeah that's the way they get into it
there's more here if you'd like some
more song Hey yeah then what are we
doing later what do you got somewhere to
be at 11:00 yeah this is really
interesting for someone that doesn't put
alcohol on their taste buds like it
really it feels really real you know and
if it tastes really good well I
appreciate you joining me on that one
out hope but hopefully I didn't put you
too hard on the spot there so we had a
we had David who will hear from meadow
cannabis as well yeah I don't do
cannabis either and so when he had an
edible on we both had one as well so
whenever our guests bring things that we
don't eat or drink or Rhonda's at all
but I don't but I always I always pay
the respect to what it is and this is
fantastic yeah we need to get Tony
Montana on the show
what's that joke oh you didn't see
Scarface oh yeah cocaine dealing never
oh I get all right let's run let's run
dick through a couple of the simulation
questions on the way out all right yeah
before we get in trouble what do we what
do we do with the concentration of
wealth in so few and then the
exacerbation of the wealth inequality
due to technologies
biotechnology space colonization
technologies AI and robotics
cryptocurrencies what do we do about
that that growing gap of inequality
yeah that's a really good question I
think it's one of the more important
questions we can be asking ourselves
right so I'm happy to answer it again
not speaking ex cathedra for long now I
don't think long bao has a position on
this kind of stuff but I'm happy to talk
about it
my personal take on it is that it's kind
of if we're asking ourselves how much
inequality is too much inequality right
that's that's a tough question to answer
for everybody like for me to answer for
everybody right and there's this
interesting thing that we have we have
the ability to kind of kick that
question down to individuals to figure
out what fuels right what think what
seems appropriate right
and so when we think about like yeah
wealth inequality and technology and how
is it exacerbated well imagine that
you're working on a technology and
imagine your technology is going to like
drastically increase the amount of
wealth and equality United States how do
you feel about that it's a question you
should be asking yourself right in these
ethical conversations we've been talking
about this opening of spaces this is
kind of creating an aperture for
questioning to happen in thinking and
conversing to happen is really important
because if that's your role you should
be having those conversations someone
should be talking with you you should be
thinking about it with yourself talking
with yourself go for a walk in the woods
because you have to come up with some
kind of modus vivendi you got to come up
with a stand
you can't even not take a stand right
like it's one thing we have to do is
even and not take a stand is to take a
stand right and so you're gonna take a
stand but so is every one of the other 7
billion people on the planet right and
so if you're in a position to influence
that you got to think about it you don't
have you know you have a responsibility
to really kind of reflect meditate on it
and find the right answer and the nice
thing about and you know it's it's
really a dodj on my part right I'm
dodging the question by saying I won't
answer that I won't say how much
inequality is too much in a part I think
we all know there's a lot of inequality
and it's problematic right I walked here
through Market Street to get here right
this is San Francisco is kind of like
heartbreaking wound right
it's Market Street and then everything
that we're talking about now right
having a delicious single malt scotch
right so these things stand in stark
juxtaposition and there's a certain
sense in which yeah it was a new sort of
position to do something about it
that's in the lyrics of the rush song by
Neil Peart and regards to a free will
even if you you don't make a choice you
still have me if you choose not to Jews
you still made a choice
yes rush philosophically yes prog rock
band Thanks thank you I was dating
myself good song I wish I knew the
lyrics on the top do you know exactly
what you're talking about do mom and I
couldn't agree more so again in a
certain sense kicking I'm kicking it off
and dodging the question but another
certain sense I actually think that's
the appropriate level of abstraction you
know it's a how much wealth inequality
is too much wealth and equality for
every single person it's different so
well it's more it's more just like we
don't make decisions that way like
there's not like a wealth equality meter
that I can just go here and say oh
here's what I think right like this I
think it's actually like to ask the
question I think it's an important
question to ask but the more you think
about it the more you go oh wait maybe
that's not that's not the question I
should be asking myself is how much
wealth inequality maybe I should be
looking at other things that I'm doing
other ways I'm acting as an agent in a
system that's either creating wealth
inequality as a secondary effect like
not like I intended to write like you
can do stuff you can have an impact on
something without area folk yeah
Madeleine do is just on the show
yesterday and he basically said that
rather than having the super poor be
here and the super rich be here we need
to just do this and make it so that the
gap between the super rich and super
poor is just much much less but there's
still this room to grow and innovate and
create an impact but the baseline is
going needs to go up much faster but
keep the ceiling going up at the same
time yeah that's a good answer but it's
people that are gonna do this it's
individuals they're gonna do this
yeah and they won't have a slider
they'll have to just go out in the world
they'll have to wake up on Monday
morning go okay cool I don't know if the
way that this that that this is going to
come to here I don't know if this is
gonna happen benevolently or
malevolently well I don't know either
and I actually have a tendency to think
that it's
to be ugly Thanks thanks for saying that
is but time we could agree on something
you let a little touch of darkness in it
there that you're aware of that but
there's bad days ahead yeah yeah there's
it's I mean just think like you just
said take a look at mid Market Street
you know a decent amount of people that
we know that have either been on the
show or that we talked to you know
totally off the record their names of
course but they have a tendency to think
that it takes a lot of resources to
invest this to come up to here is it
worth the resources to invest into human
psychology mental stability physical
stability and wellness is it worth the
time and the resources that we've heard
that before
is it worth it is it worth investing a
lot of time and money and resources to
bring people up from the very bottom to
at least the middle or the middle upper
and why why try and teach the old horses
new tricks when you could just birth new
horses that are already way up here that
you can train to be even better horses
you can just kill off dogs
what's God you know talking about horses
right we're not talking about killing
anything off right talk about human
beings and that changes the calculus I
think right and again like what was what
I was getting at yeah using a horse
though just as just an analogy but yeah
but I think that's some of that's some
of the some of the way we structure the
way we're thinking about it is actually
the stuff we should be thinking about so
it's less I guess like I was saying
before with a slider comparison right
some of its think about the question and
some of its think about the questions
we're asking and ask ourselves like I
met a question is this the question we
should be asking is it really is it
really a question we should be asking is
like is it worth to it to invest in
people is it worth it to invest in you
know other people with which we share a
neighborhood with which we share a
country with which we share a planet is
that that's that's an interesting
question I think we have to take a
and on that do you think it's worth it
but then let's also talk about like what
is it we're really talking about right
because we're not just talking about
demographics we're not talking about you
know some 10,000 units of something
right we're talking about individual
human beings and I think there's really
strong arguments there that like that
changes the way we should ask the
question so that would kind of be my
answer is like I think we should take
that question and all everything around
it I think we need to take that back to
the wood shop all of us collectively and
really say like are we asking the right
questions because I don't know if the
answers we're getting from the questions
that we've been asking because we've
been in even in San Fran school for how
many years yes I've been here for like
half that time right like three years
and all the questions we're asking like
the questions haven't changed the
answers really haven't totally changed a
whole lot either there's kind of like a
bottleneck logjam kind of thing going on
and I think we can think about it better
and again this becomes conversationally
mediated it becomes reflectively
mediated so I'm interested to figure out
how to ask the question better and to
get more conversations rolling around
the world about it because just the
general increasing that bottom and
decreasing that gap but continuing
innovation and creativity through onward
in the futures now you're having a great
cover like you're opening the
conversation with the show and that's
amazing and if you're asking lots of
people this question if I'll be hearing
a lot of interesting things totally
that's awesome that you're doing that do
you want a little more good oh thank you
though appreciate um so I have a another
question is do you think we're alone in
the cosmos alone as yeah
short answer is no short answer is yeah
absolutely no like hard no do you think
there are advanced civilizations roaming
the cosmos that one I don't know because
I again like the question itself is like
what are we looking for right are we
looking for civilizations like us
looking for carbon-based life-forms we
look at you know I mean do we consider
technology to be a marker of advanced
civilization or as a species that's
avoided the technological question
altogether are they doing a tip-top job
we're gonna evolve in a thousand years
to have eyes yeah yeah what is this you
know and it's it's an interesting
question I think again it's like one of
these provocative questions it gets the
juices flowing
it gets the words out of me
I think it's the words out of you and
we're swapping perspectives you know and
we get to talk a little bit I think it's
really important yeah but I don't know I
don't know what we're gonna find one out
there I'm glad people are listening do
you think we're in a computer simulation
um yeah so my my answer and that one is
mostly that uh if we're in a simulation
obviously these things nest right so
statistically speaking the argument for
I think I presume your viewership is
familiar with the simulation hypothesis
right the the argument is that like oh
you're in a simulation but that
simulation could have been seeded from
inside of another simulation right and
so you can go down this like ad
infinitum and all of a sudden like
you're just and you know it's Turtles
all the way down kind of thing right and
so the real important question that I
think we should be asking about the
simulation is less are we in one or not
because we've already said by setting up
the hypothesis that we wouldn't know
even if we were right so are we in it or
not and it's does it change the way you
behave
does it actually inform or instruct the
way you act in the world do you dwell in
the world differently if you think it's
just a simulation the more I talk about
the simulation the more I want to
advance civilization to the point where
we can make a simulation so that's one
thing that expands people's minds to new
dimensions of thinking as well yeah it
doesn't change your behavior on a
day-to-day basis I know probably not we
don't know
it's just a thought but it seems to be
the latest and greatest it's changed the
way you think though it expands your
minds to new dimensions so I guess it
does it's a good question Bureau it's a
good question
yeah what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world oh man it's
a good question the most beautiful thing
in the world
I think oh man I I think that look that
people give me when they hear about the
clock and it's the first time ever I
think that's my favorite thing in the
world I'm just seeing like that human
experience that just draws out all that
empathy and just like kind of like you
can just tell there's like fireworks
going off and someone's head I love that
feeling and when you're having a
conversation when you ask me a question
I'm like oh my god what's the most
beautiful thing that's great
like that kind of connection that
ability to kind of poke somebody at a
deep level and I can really kind of open
up something with them I think is really
people yeah hell yeah that's a good one
what I think long now probably talks
about this a decent amount but how do we
work together across the borders of the
world yeah god man again like I don't
think I have the authority to come up
with a good answer for that right how do
we you know do that I think again like I
think I think individual human beings
figure that out figure that out in your
own small way you know I think it's
forget which suture it is but it's the
Buddhist idea of like you keep your
golden link in the chain shiny it's your
responsibility is that golden link right
and I really think that's the case right
like I think our world kind of moves on
individual people doing really wonderful
amazing things so I think what do I do
I don't know I'm here talking to you I'm
sharing this information for the show
I'm working for long now I'm having
conversations about the future and what
we should be doing and that's the move
I've got that's my that's my Lincoln
that's really yeah this is our Lincoln
as we typically say on the show find
your link we don't say it that way but
we talk about you guys finding your link
and Shia keeping it shining keeping a
golden lien keeping the link strong with
the other people around you you guys use
that on the show that was our first time
we use the link that's awesome first
time we use the link we usually say that
if you had a good time share the content
with other people and usually what we
tell people is furthermore go build
something with the content so if you got
inspired to go build something go write
something go create something with it go
talk to other people about it comment
below with your thoughts give us a like
give us to subscribe check out long now
there links in the bio go find Nick
online as well as links in the bio as
well reach out to him get in touch
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it
also if you had a good time help support
us on patreon we're trying to sustain
this studio and grow it and grow our
impact out so join us there much love of
Nick thanks so much for joining thanks
on the show really sure oh absolutely we
have a lot more great conversation great
impact to keep coming yeah so awakening
rosetta projects extinction the clock
the interval manual of civilization all
this amazing work that you guys have
done and we're gonna keep amplifying
impacting around Vargas are producing
director and partner thank you very much
much love everyone peace thank you thank
you this is so cool man
what a great setup Thanks let's let's
figure out how we can do it
[Music]